dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here how about
some slow-motion videos if we would like
to create a slow-motion video and we
don't own an expensive slow-mo camera we
can try to shoot a normal video and
simply slow it down this sounds good on
paper however the more we slow it down
the more space we have between our
individual frames and at some point our
video will feel more like a slideshow to
get around this problem in a previous
video we discussed two basic techniques
to fill in these missing frames one was
a knife technique called frame blending
that basically computes the average of
two images in most cases this doesn't
help all that much because it doesn't
have an understanding of the motion that
takes place in the video
the other one was optical flow now this
one is much smarter as it tries to
estimate the kind of translation and
rotational motions that take place in
the video and they typically do much
better however the disadvantage of this
is that it usually takes forever to
compute and it often introduces visual
artifacts so now we are going to have a
look at Nvidia's results and the main
points of interest are always around the
silhouettes of moving objects especially
around regions where the foreground and
the background meet keep an eye out for
these regions throughout this video
for instance here is one example I found
let me know in the comment section if
you have found more this technique
builds on you net a super fast
convolutional neural network
architecture that was originally used to
segment biomechanical images from
limited training data this neural
network was trained on a bit over a
thousand videos and computes multiple
approximate optical flows and combines
them in a way that tries to minimize
artifacts as you see in the side-by-side
comparisons it works amazingly well some
artifacts still remain but are often
hard to catch and this architecture is
blazing fast not real-time yet but
creating a few tens of these additional
frames takes only a few seconds the
quality of the results is also evaluated
and compared to other works in the paper
make sure to have a look as the current
commercially available tools are super
slow and take forever I cannot wait to
be able to use this technique to make
some more amazing slow-motion footage
for you fellow scholars thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time